this story is so sad
a january sixther has just been
sentenced to seven years in prison
and he's been sentenced to seven years
in prison
after his son his 19 year old son turned
on him turned him in testified against
him
i actually remember this story when it
first bubbled up in the media many
months ago this is guy refit
49 years old convicted of five felonies
in march
and now looking at seven years in prison
the sun 19 year old son said that that
he was disgusted by his father showing
up to the capitol in washington dc on
january 6th i don't even know that the
father ever even went inside the capitol
i think he may have just been on the
capitol grounds
the son was disgusted by this the son
said that the father threatened him and
his sister if they turned him in the
sister contradicts this narrative the
sister sided with the father
the son testified against the father
what's so sad about this is not only the
two-tiered justice system because if if
the father had instead been up on
charges related to much worse charges
at a blm rally forget about the capital
january 6th if the this guy guy refit
had done 10 times whatever he did at the
capitol on behalf of the blm
organization he
he probably wouldn't have been arrested
he probably wouldn't have been certainly
wouldn't have been charged maybe a
little slap on the wrist from the
officer don't do that again he'd be
right back on the street but because
he's a trump supporter he's looking at
seven years in the can that's not even
the worst part we know about the
two-tier justice system what is so
sickening to me about this story
is the the destruction of this family
that this
political movement
by which i'm talking about the left
has turned a family
against each other
i'm not just talking about i'm not
saying that the the right wing is
blameless or the one
but i but i am saying this is being
driven by the left
okay the january sixth
witch hunt the show trial the selective
prosecutions the two-tier justice system
has created such political pressure and
demonized
half the country as terrorists and
insurrectionists and traitors and
threats to the country
that
you've now got families pitted against
each other a son testifying against his
father which is what the liberals want
that is what the libs are after they are
after the destruction of the family they
are after the destruction of the family
because the family is the impediment to
their power
because the family is the
fundamental political unit
the libs believe that the fundamental
political unit is the individual
that's what they want it to be when you
can break down all of society into just
individuals then it's much easier to
gobble them all up into a collective
leftist political movements have known
this for
centuries
the conservatives believe that the
fundamental unit of society is not the
individual it's the family that's why we
support not only the family but other
associations and civic institutions
because those are mediating
mediating institutions between the
individual and the all-encompassing
state
and the libs want to destroy that and
the basic one they want to destroy is
the family this is why you're seeing the
groomer movement from the left this is
why you're seeing the left go into
elementary schools and say hey kids talk
to us about sex don't talk to your
families about sex hey your name's not
really johnny your name's jane now i'm
gonna call you jane i'm not gonna call
you he i'm gonna call you she we're
gonna get you on cross-sex hormones
don't tell your parents
we're gonna pass laws that that will
allow us to groom you in this sexual way
without ever notifying your parents
we're gonna pass laws to allow you to
kill your children through abortion and
never have to notify your parents we
want to get between the child and the
parents we think that the parents the
family is a terrible influence on the
kids we think that we the state are a
good influence on the kids so that's why
we're going to suppress the family and
we're going to encourage the growth of
the state that's what you see in
abortion
what is abortion it's the clearest sort
of policy to destroy the family you're
literally killing the kids you are
killing the possibility of the family
this is why you see the articles every
time thanksgiving or christmas rolls
around all these left-wing articles how
to talk to your crazy conservative uncle
at the table even though you ha you have
to talk to him and here's how here's how
you can get through that conversation
and convince him to be a leftist and i
say this i am a crazy conservative uncle
i am the uncle they're talking about
okay and so i know i've had these
conversations
you don't see that from from the right
very rarely do you see from the right
how to talk to your lesbian transgender
left-wing cousin at the dinner table we
just we say how do you talk to your your
left-wing relatives the same way you
talk to your right-wing relatives you
treat them like your family because
blood is thicker than water and blood is
thicker than the cnn airwaves okay
that's what conservatives believe
the left wing thinks that political
ideology trumps every single thing else
and they look at the family as the enemy
it's a consistent pattern here
and so
when when a family is destroyed because
of this january 6th stuff
no one's blameless i'm not saying any
any political movement is totally
pristine and angelic that doesn't exist
in politics but this is being driven by
the left and when that happens the left
is a giddy to watch a family break up
you want to talk about family there's a
story i meant to get to yesterday
sydney sweeney
is an actress on the handmaid's tale
you probably have not watched the
handmaid's tale i have not i did watch a
few of the first episodes just to see
what it was about i couldn't keep
watching it was just so it just seems
kind of like
soft core porn for women just seems like
kind of these weird sexual fantasies
that women have that is that's not based
on reality it's not it's not we're not
living in anything like the handmaid's
tale in america but but women have this
kind of fantasy that we are sort of like
50 shades of grey so i said okay this is
too weird i'm not going to keep watching
this but sydney sweeney apparently is
one of the actresses on handmaid's tale
and she just came out
and complained about the way that
hollywood treats women and she didn't
complain about it in the usual way
and she didn't complain about it about
the treatment of women in the way you
might expect from the handmaid's tale
which is that the conservatives and the
patriarchy and the right wing is
oppressing women no it was the opposite
it was that leftism
feminism
is harming women
she says
i want to have a family i've always
wanted to be a young mom and i'm worried
about how this industry puts stigmas on
young women who have children and looks
at them in a different light
i was worried that if i don't work
there's no money and no support for kids
that i would have
she made this complaint to amy adams
and amy adams told her no it can be done
you can have kids at a young age but the
insecurities over her financial health
and the momentum of her career remain
years later this this young woman i
think is 24 she's in her mid-20s
somewhere
very very sad how confused she is
and it's and it's very sad that that
hollywood does put the stigma on women
who have families
it's almost as if
the real threats to women
are not coming from the conservatives
they're coming from the leftists it's
almost as if the handmaid's tale is
depicting the opposite of reality it's
almost as if feminism isn't really good
for women it's almost as if ever since
the advent of feminism in the 1970s
modern feminism you've seen women's
happiness consistently decline both in
absolute terms and relative to men
it's almost as if leftism is a total
psyop and it's making women completely
miserable
a family would make this woman happy
it's it's not just me making an
observation she knows that too and she
feels that she can't support the family
why not well she says well what if i
don't make enough money i can't work and
that's an amazing statement
she's a beautiful successful young woman
did it never occur to her that when she
has a child
she would be she would do that in a
marriage
and that her husband might work and be
able to support her while she's taking
care of her child
it's amazing this woman believes that
she is going to have to carry the burden
entirely herself she's going to have to
make all the money she's going to have
to care for the kid entirely herself
she's going to have to continue to work
and she's they're not going to want her
to work because hollywood doesn't like
mothers hollywood doesn't like families
hollywood likes people to remain 19
years old forever
and and when women age they want to
encourage them to pretend to be 19 years
old forever
it's never occurred to her and i bet
that's true for a lot of women
but ladies there is another option
you could get married you could take
care of your kid not all of life is
about money not all of life of life is
about looking young forever not all of
life is about what feminism tells you
life is about
and and the real oppression the real
things that are making you miserable
it's not coming from those right wingers
it's not coming from the people they
tell you to fear it's coming from your
own
sides i'm glad you like that cliff folks
we hit
a million subscribers on the youtube
channel we did that pretty much
two days before my second baby boy was
born into this world it's a good week is
what i'm saying now let's turn it up a
notch let's take that 1 million
subscribers let's make it 1 billion i
want 1 billion youtube subscribers
please ring the bell subscribe get the
notifications we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]